sur le bord de cette route à donner deux
corps sans vie juste au sol
mercredi cette zone dans la partie Est
de l'Ukraine contrôlée par les Russes a
été bombardé plusieurs personnes ont
également été blessées le maire de la
ville prorus accuse les autorités
ukrainiennes
sur place la population est encore sous
le choc
un garçon a couru du pont à notre porte
s'il avait 14 ou 15 ans il a dit qu'il
avait deux filles avec lui près du pont
il a dit que l'une d'elles allait bien
mais que l'autre était grièvement
blessée
à la joindre alors il a couru un nouveau
vers le pont je sais pas s'ils sont
vivants en
Ukraine les civils continuent d'être eux
aussi victimes de la guerre au moins 11
sont morts mardi à cramatorzek seul
grande ville de l'Est du pays encore
contrôlée par Kiev le président
ukrainien volodières ski a annoncé
mercredi soir l'arrestation de celui qui
aurait coordonné l'attaque alors que le
Kremlin ni tout implication sur une
vibration aujourd'hui les services de
sécurité et les forces spéciales de la
police ont arrêté la personne qui a
coordonné cette attaque terroriste ils
ont frappé un café à 14 une pizzeria
populaire
les forces ukrainiennes continuent leur
contre-offensive dans l'est du pays qui
est assure avoir repris plusieurs
villages dans la région de deniers